Okay, welcome everyone to today's DDPS seminar.
Before we go into actual you know, the fun part,
like the actual presentations, let
me go over some logistics as usual.
This The talk is going to be recorded and will
be available in Youtube channel, and also it's,
it's, it's open to the external audiences, so no
classify this question. Please watch out for that,
and please mute yourself during the talk.
And if you have questions, you
can unmute and ask questions,
but if or you could, you know, leave your
questions in the chat chat room. Alright,
so that's about it for the logistics. And let me
introduce our speaker today. I'm, I'm honored to,
you know, Host A,
the Young Jun Hong who is an associate
professor at Seoul National University,
and he focuses his research on the mathematics of
machine learning and its application in scientific
computing. He earned his PhD in mathematics with
a minor in scientific computing from Indiana
University under the guidance of Professor Walter
hemam, where he developed a strong foundation
in theoretical analysis and computational
techniques during his postdoc work at the
University of Illinois at Chicago with
Professor Jerry Bona and David Nichols,
he conducted research on electromagnetic and water
waves for the honing his problem solving skills.
He later initiated independent studies on the
use of neural networks in scientific research,
leading to a focused research program at
San Diego State University where he began
investigating neural network approximation within
scientific machine learning. Currently, his work
is dedicated to developing theoretical frameworks
that enhance the reliability and applicability
of neural networks in addressing complex
scientific and engineering challenges. Today,
Professor Hong on jun is going to present us on
his work on operator networks based
on numerical analysis. I'm sure he's
going to give a fantastic talk before I
pass the button to him, let me ask you.
Well, I'm sorry I'm lost connection.
Yeah, no, I think young soo
lost the connection. Okay,
I'm so sorry. Yes, I lost my
connection. My computer just
shut down on me all of a
sudden. I'm sorry about that,
but I was able to connect back
pretty quickly using my cell phone
technology. Hopefully the
recording is still going on.
Okay, so recording is still going on.
Okay, awesome, okay, so I think I was
about to ask a questions, right? Young
Jun, so my question is, if you can,
you know, share your story how you
ended up with on this research field,
like the scientific computing and
the computational science, etc.
If you can share some story,
especially for the for the young, you
know students, that would be very helpful.
Thanks. Um, first of all, thanks for very
nice introduction. And it's my honor to
speak in the present in the DDPS seminar. So
from the young switch questions. So in fact,
when I start my PhD, I have no idea about
the scientific computing and, of course,
machine learning, this kind of thing.
Actually, I want to study some theoretical
mathematics at the beginning. And I attend my
advisors, my former advisors class, which is
navier stokes equations and some
kind of the numerical schemes and
theoretical numerical analysis. And
then I dive into the kind of the new
research. And it's fascinating.
So I love it. And I just saw.
That, okay, this is the, the the area I want to
study right now. And then I dive into this kind
of area, and it's very, very interesting to me.
So in fact, um, there is a no special reason to
me. There are no kind of special moment to me.
But, um, I gradually like this kind of the um,
the scientific computing and machine
learning field. In them, there are many
good collaborators and friends that in the
laboratory, the my advisor to labs, and I can
interact with many of the my the wonderful
colleagues and the co workers at the time.
And yeah, I think that's the reason, because
the subject is fit. It's very interesting to me,
and there are many, you know, nice collaborators
to work with me. So I think, um, you know,
that's one of the reason. And the other reason is,
um, scientifically, I want to study this kind of,
the some, some real world application problem.
That's another reason for me, for the moment,
I guess you're, you know, born to be a, you
know, walk in the scientific machine learning.
Well, thank you. Stage is yours. Okay? Thanks. So
once again, thanks to the thanks to Professor, Dr
TRA and the DDPS seminar organizers. Um, so it's
my honor to speak here. So I'm today. I'm talking
about the operating networks based on the miracle
analysis. So, um, I think, um, everybody knows
what's the scientific machine learning right now.
So I don't need to speak of this kind of the what
is the scientific machine learning? What it is,
what it is, but, um, yeah, long story too. Short,
it's like the machine learning plus scientific
computing. So we are going to solve some, um,
some scientific and engineering or mathematical
physics problems by using data driven or sometimes
some kind of the machine learning techniques.
So each kind of the new area and the which
multidisciplinary area. So it's very interesting
to me for the moment, okay, for though, I'm
talking about the AI today. I'm a mathematician.
So before I dive into this kind of the machine
learning fields, I'm studying this kind of the
boundary layer and singular perturbation in
fluids, ocean circulation problem, and sometimes
some navier stokes like equation. I studied this
kind of, the singular perturbation and boundary
layer and sometimes interior layer problems.
And also I studied the electromagnetic wave
numerically by using some kind of spectral
element methods and finite element methods. And
I studied this kind of the basically, I saw the
Maxa equation by using the some numerical methods
this period layered medium problem. So that's one
of my subjects. And also I studied Geophysical
Fluid Dynamics. So this is a famous the primitive
equations, which is good for the numerical weather
prediction. And I'm using the finite volume method
and then solving the some kind of, this kind of
the range of the effects by using this kind of,
excuse me if this kind of the primitive
equations. But right now my interest is
in the machine learning and scientific
computing in the combination of this
in between them. So I want to make a
bridge between scientific computing and
machine learning and make a good
development and good improvement
for this kind of a new fields, new research
fields. So okay, so the right now the
scientific machine learning, we have a two kind
of the famous option, one for the physics informed
option, and the other one is data driven options.
So many people knows what the physics inform your
networks and dim reach methods. So they are
not using some kind of the data driven methods,
but they are, you know, successfully find
them solution for the given PD problems.
And another field is data driven method. So it's
so called the new operator. And they are, they we
have two famous new operator. One is devonet. The
other one is fully neuro operator. And then they
are, they are kind of the data driven sometimes
they don't use data, but normally they're using
the data driven methods. And then they can find
numerical solution with multiple instances. So
there are two kind of the big two area to research
fields, like the physics informed and data driven.
So let's talk about just a little bit more detail
about the physics info neural networks. So this
is famous physics inform your network. So we have
the special coordination and temporal coordinate,
TN, x, and then we can predict the
given solution. And how can we train
this guy? We can train this guy by using the
register information. And so this is like the,
for instance, we are going to
solve the burgers equation.
Equation, integer condition and boundary
condition. These are all the registered
information or into the this kind of the Ross
function. And then they can using the auto
gradient and auto differentiation by using the
pytorch or TensorFlow. And then they can find
this kind of the derivative term. And then they
can training this kind of the burgers equation
solution. So it's pretty much well known,
and then it's very powerful, because I'm,
you know, basically mesh free, and we don't
need to know the this kind of the data driven
approach for that. So that's the physics inform
your networks. And the other one is operator
running. So one of the, you know, drawback
for the physics in front of neural networks,
this is they can only predict single instances,
so if they want to find another solution,
they changing the first income initial condition,
they have to train once again. So to overcome this
drawback, the researchers find them this kind of
operator learning so they can handle the multiple
instances, but they need some kind of the input,
output, pair, data set for the training process.
So basically the operator networks, they can
learn this kind of the mapping. So input is
for instance, input is like the initial
condition, and they can predict. They can
find mapping for this kind of the T is equal
to point 5t. Is equal to one. So given time,
the solution data, a solution for
the given PDE, s, so they just find,
they just basically learn the mapping from
initial condition to the specific solution.
Initial condition to specific solution.
Or sometimes they give a false income and
then find a solution. So they can do multiple
instances. So they can change initial condition,
they can change the first income, then without
further training, they can predict the numerical
solution. So that's the operator like, operator
learning, operator networks. And, you know, they
can do the multiple instance. It's pretty much
efficient in terms of the engineering perspective.
So, and then this kind of approach is pretty much
natural in the computer vision
task, because computer vision,
they have some kind of input image, they can
predict the output image. So each kind of the
computer vision, each kind of the mapping
process. So they can do, for instance,
we have this kind of poison equation. So input
is this kind of the forcing term M, output is
the given solution. So input that output pair,
and then they can have this kind of the neural
networks. They can learn this kind of mapping, so
which is pretty much natural in the sense of the
computer vision task, but we are going to use this
kind of thing in in the the solving PD problems.
So one of the,
you know, big branch is so called the
deep one. So deep on it, they have a
two different network, branch and trunk
networks. So I, in my understanding this
trunk networks is kind of the basis
prediction. And branch network each
kind of the coefficient predictions. So they can
have some kind of the summation coefficient and
basis and then they can predict the
good approximation solution. That's
my interpretation. And free neural networks,
fNo, so which is also pretty much famous, and
so they have some kind of the stack
of the batch file on the data,
and then they can influence the next time
steps, this kind of solution set. So they
are smartly using this kind of the convolution
relation, and then they're using the inverse and
forward the Fourier transform. So input is kind
of the, for instance, initial condition and for
symptom, and then using the encoder. And then
they have a many Fourier layer in between. And
output is decoder, and this is solution. And this
real layer consists of this kind of the MLP layer,
and plus Fourier and inverse for it Fourier
transform. And then this R is kind of the
reduction, so they can just get rid of
the high frequency, and then they can just
handle the row frequency stone. And then they
can adding it. This is one free layer. And then
they can process this many, the many free layer,
and then they can find them the nice numerical
solution. And this kind of the process interpreted
as this kind of the convolution operation. So I
think of it, the idea is very smart. So I like
this kind of method. But I'm not going to talk
about today about this kind of the known the
operator networks. I'm going to talk about
the new operator networks, which is based on
the numerical analysis and numerical methods.
So what is the pros and cons of the pins
and operation networks? I think this is
like the pretty much well known part.
So pins are very easy to implement,
and each basically mesh free, so
they can handle various domain and
equation and each basically unsupervised
learning. Some people, they say this is.
Same, improvised. Okay, it depends
on their philosophy and they but,
but the negative part is they can
predict only one single PD instance,
and then maybe it's hard to impose the exact
boundary condition and operator network,
they can predict multiple instances so called.
They can solve the parameter PDS, and they can
use many, you know, new trend of the computer
vision architecture, like transformer and unit,
this kind of the architecture and the one of the
the minus part each supervisor learning. So they
need them pre competed input output data set by
using the numerical PD method. And then sometimes
they have some kind of generalization error,
the high generalization error kind of thing.
And
let's just this is like the some one of the
limitation advantage for the scientific machine
learning. So the limitation of the scientific
module learning is we don't have, like, some
kind of concrete error analysis, and accuracy is
not very high, and training time is too long. So
each kind of the limitation, but nevertheless, we
need to study this kind of the scientific machine
learning, because the advantage is very, very, you
know, interesting, because they can overcome curse
of dimensionality, because, I mean, sampling
basis, and they can do the fast inference,
and they can handle inverse problem very nicely.
And potentially they can handle complex problem,
and by using this kind of the machine learning,
the expressive power, they can handle this kind
of the complex problem. So these, these kind of
advantages, are very fascinating to me, so that's
why I'm studying this kind of scientific machine
learning right now. Okay, so this is a very quick
introduction. So now I'm going to talk about the
operator networks with an eight of the numerics.
So I think everybody in this room knows what's the
numerical method for PDE? There are three famous
the numerical PD method. Of course, there
are maybe four to five different methods,
but I'm going to talk about the finite difference
and finite element and spectrum methods. Of course
we need to study with finite volume method,
bounded element method. But you know, I think
if you want to study more, then you can just read
the more textbook and more papers. But today I'm
going to more or less focus on spectral method and
finite element method, basically finite element
spectral method, spectral element method. They
are relying on this kind of the weak formulation,
and they need this kind of basis function, finite
element method, basis function is local basis
spectral method, spectral element method, they
are, they are using the global basis function,
which is also on a polynomial so and like
maybe over 50 years, many of mathematician,
engineers and physicists studies finite element,
spectral element, find a different methods,
and there are many different branches. There many
different, you know, the methodology for solving
the given underlying governing PD problems. So as
I said, finite element method and finite spectral
element method I'm going to talk about today. So
find an element which is good for the irregular
and structured mesh, and then they need, you need
to use a local basis function. And the accuracy
is, it depends on the order of the polynomial.
If they're using the first order polynomial,
the accuracy is not that high. But if they using
the high order polynomial, then accuracy, they
have a very high accuracy. And then competition
cost is quite moderate. And then, if you think
about the spectral element method, they are
using the global basis function. And then,
like the Fourier general and Chebyshev polynomial,
and they have a very high accuracy using the
very small number of the polynomial. They can
use the high accuracy in numerical solution,
but sometimes computational cost is very high
and they can handle just boxer like domain kind
of the problem in general. Of course, there
are many different methods, but normally the
global basis function is good for the this kind of
the, you know, box, like domain, domain problem,
so
motivated by the spectral method and finite
element method. Okay, let me start from the
spectrum method. I'm going to explain the operator
networks based on this kind of spectrum method.
So this is a given
elliptic problem. I said this is 2d but not
necessarily 2d 1d 2d 3d 4d doesn't matter. So
this is like the elliptic problem. And then
we can find reformulation from this kind of
a problem. And this is given boundary condition.
And then once we make this kind of a formulation,
we can use the the Galar method, we
can find this kind of the solution,
solution approximation. And this v x, v k,
this is basis function. So if you want to go
for the Legendre polynomial, like this kind of
a Legendre polynomial, then the basis function.
Consists of this kind of the linear combination
of three different Legendary polynomial. And then
this a k, b, k, can be determined by the given
boundary condition. For instance, if you have a
particular boundary condition, a K, zero became
negative one. If you want to have a homogeneous
no even boundary condition, then this is zero. And
this is like this kind of the formulation. And of
course, you can do the login boundary condition,
and you can find a k and b k. It depends on the
your the boundary condition, and, um, well, this
kind of the formulation, actually, I just am
talking about the Legendre, the Legendre spectrum
method. But if you want to go for the Chevy chef
or Fourier, or the other better function, or
Jacobi polynomial, then you can use another
polynomial. Basically, the method is pretty much
same, and mu formulation is pretty much same.
So what is my strategy? So normally,
when we think about the Galerkin method,
so your solution UX, then you can interpret
your solution by using this kind of the simple
approximation. And this v k is known
polynomial like Legendre, Chebyshev,
whatever. And this alpha k, which is
unknowns, we are going to solve this
alpha k by using the numerical method,
like Ax equal to b, kind of the method.
And so my idea is, okay, so this VK, we all know
this VK is good polynomial, because in numerics,
we studied this kind of the basis function
for 50 years, like the Legendre polynomial
and Chip shape polynomial, whatever this is, we
can know this kind of the information of this
VK. So my strategy is that, what if we can only
predict this alpha k by using the neural networks,
and then we can make this kind of summation we I
call this one is reconstruction. Then we can find
this kind of accurate numerical solution by using
this approximation. So our input each given f,
so I just naively make this kind of a simple
random F. So given f, we can predict alpha k
by using the neural networks. And once we predict
alpha k, we can find this kind of by using this
kind of the reconstruction, we can find this UN
our numerical solution. That is simple idea. And
how can we and then the problem is,
how can we build our loss function
to train this kind of neural network
from F to alpha k, given F to alpha k?
So the idea is, we can make use of the loss
function at the reform loss term. So for instance,
very simple point problem like minus epsilon, u
xx minus UX equal to f, and then zero boundary
condition. And we know, how can we build this
kind of the reformulation, and then this VJ
are this kind of the test function. And then by
integration by parts, we can, you know, make this
kind of term by using the integration by parts.
Then this is the left hand side minus right hand
side. We want to make this is zero. If this is
zero, then our UN is good UN. And then, you know,
this is our The Lost term. And then the question
is, how can we pick up this kind of the feature,
VJ is just test function. We have many options,
many choices. But if we want to go further this
kind of the Legendre spectral method, then this
v j are our Legendre basis function. Because of
this UN can be interpreted as this kind of alpha
k and v k, and this v k is same V J, like the same
Legendre polynomial that we can use gauss Legendre
quadrature. The numerical integration is very
high accuracy numerical integration. So we are
going to use that kind of the numerical analysis
technique. And well, this kind of derivative
also exact, because we know this form of the VJ
Legendre polynomial, we know how to how to make
a derivative for the given Legendre polynomial.
And also this UN which consists of alpha, k and v
k summation, we know what's the exact derivative
for this part. So, you know, we don't need to take
them any kind of the numerical differentiation. So
we can reduce the error once again. So they these
are the architecture for the legendary galactic
neural networks, so our given x for symptom F,
and our neural networks, whatever the neural
networks is, we can predict this coefficient alpha
k, and once we predict this coefficient alpha k,
we can reconstruct solution u hat, and then
once we can reconstruct solution u hat,
then we can make this kind of loss function.
And then once we can make this loss function,
then we can train this neural networks.
And there you can, you know, go and go and
go in this process, then you can find accurate
alpha k, as long as this process is, you know,
well set up, well defined. So that's the basic
idea of the Legendre Galar neural network.
Works. Idea is very simple,
and I tested this kind of 1d to the convection
definition equation boundary condition, and then
Helmholtz equation, with the Neumann homogeneous
Neumann boundary condition, and also this burgers
equation. So the geo boundary zero boundary
condition, and burgers equation is non linear
problem. So normally in numerics, we need to think
about the iterative method, the Newton method,
or fixed point method. But our
idea, we just predict alpha k,
that's it. So we don't need to do the iteration
process when we influence the solution,
this solution to the progress equation.
So that's another good part of that
is kind of the spectral coefficient,
learning the operating network method.
So convection diffusion, harmonic equation,
we can find accurate solution. So this is
a zero boundary condition case convection
diffusion, and this is the new one boundary
condition case of the hero multi equation, we
can find them quite accurate solution. In fact,
this simulation is done maybe few years ago, so
right now we can do the 10 to negative five or
six, very high accuracy numerical solution.
At the time, we didn't use them. You know,
the nice the neural network architectures I just
showed, the only solution, just each very, quite
accurate in that sense. But right now we have
more accurate solution by using the modernized
neural networks. And so this is the burger
situation with regular boundary condition,
also non linear burglation. We have quite
accurate solution. And also I'm going to dive
into this kind of the boundary layer problem.
But, you know, boundary layer problem, we can
also find very accurate solution. So I'm going to
talk about this boundary layer later, in detail,
and also to the problem. We can actually get the
problem. This is the our the predictive solution.
And this is an exact solution. We have relative
Altera 10 to negative four ish, so which is quite
accurate. So we can do the also 2d cases. And then
once we've done this kind of the electric type,
then we dive into the travel type of the problem.
So time dependent case. So time dependent case,
we have a u of t derivative. So the main question
is, how can we handle this? The time derivative.
So the one of the very naive, naive way, but
which is very popular way, we can just using the
Euler method, implicit Euler on Runge Kutta,
kind of the numerical time derivative. So we
can apply this kind of numerical time derivative.
Then this is kind of the UN plus one minus un
over divided by delta t, then they can become,
again, one of the analytic type of the problem.
So we can iteratively influence this kind
of the analytic type of the our the neural
networks. Then the other process is pretty
much same. So we can, you know, reduce our
problem by using the time discretization,
by using the classical numerical method,
and also we can do the trickle and Neumann and
periodic many different boundary conditions.
And the basic idea is pretty much
same. The only difference is we have
to handle this the time derivative
parts by using the cholesterol,
numerical time discretization part so that's
basically our idea. So each time derivative,
part time discretization, we have a different
neural networks. But we don't have like,
the 100 or 1000 of the neural networks here. We
have only 10 neural networks because one time
set they can these neural networks can predict,
like, the 10th step of the time. And this can,
this guy also can predict 10 step of the time.
So we can stack this kind of thing and then make
a one big V formulation. Then we can training
everything. And then this is kind of all of
the this processes, like the automation. So,
you know, everything is automatic, so we can
influence very quickly this kind of the whole
the training, the whole the influence process.
So for the time dependent problem, we
have diffusion reaction equation. We have
a non linear term and viscose Fergus and advection
equation and convection diffusion and gram of the
shabansky and navier stokes equation into D, and
we have various different boundary condition. So
sometimes we have a zero boundary condition,
sometimes we have, you know, periodic boundary
condition, and sometimes we have a normal boundary
condition. But every different boundary condition,
it works very well because, in fact, we have a
this kind of the approximation alpha, k plus V, K,
the basis function. In fact, the basis function
has information of the boundary condition. So
that's why our boundary error is zero. It's exact.
So that's another good part of the our method.
Okay, so, um, the viscose progress equation. We.
And predict pretty much well. So
we compare our method with some
two different the unsupervised neural networks,
Pinot physics inform your operator and Python,
which is some physics informed dibel net. So
these are famous unsupervised neural networks,
and then our SEC Lo and spectral
coefficient learning, operator
networks. This is some oblivation Our method,
this red one, which is the error is very low
compared to the other method. Oh, by the
way, I didn't mention too much about this.
As you know, our loss function,
we didn't use any information of
the input output pair. So our method is not
data driven, so our method is unsupervised,
so we don't need any kind of pre completed data
set. So that is another, you know, the important
part for the our method. So that's why I compare
our method wisdom, Pinot and Python together,
and then the relative error
is mature than the other two
methods, and diffusion reaction, advection,
we compare to the PI the Python and the other
method. And you know, our method is like the low
accuracy. So accuracy is very low. So you know
the method is working very well. And in this
case, advection equation, we cannot we don't
have any kind of reference the method, so it
only show our the numerical the prediction,
so exact and scoring our method each
well, quite accurate. So error is like
10 to negative three. So time dependent problem.
It's also working quite well. And we move into
the quite complicated problem, to the ground,
to mask, and to the Navier Stokes, of course,
our method, well, it's not super, super great,
but each like the 10 to negative two ish error,
like the 2% error, but you know, each working.
So that's another, you know, to the example.
And so that's like the error comparison
table. So our method, one the other direction
to the grammatical we have 1%
error. And the other method,
we compare with this one with Python. And
then, well, our, our the performance is better
than Python physics in from d1, at and this
equation, our error is better than physics,
info neural net operator because of our
relative error is more, more or less 2% error.
So that's kind of the numerical accuracy for
our the method. So again, our method is like
unsupervised neural networks. So we didn't compare
our method with the FA no and Devo net directly.
So after doing this process, as I mentioned, this
is based, basically based on the spectral element
method, but spectral element method, which is
not good for the complex geometry, like the
polygonal shape of the geometry. So I want to
do the some kind of the complicated geometry,
like this circular or circle the hole with the
square and polygon shape sometime endorphin. So
this example came from the Phenix. So, so can we
handle this kind of a complex geometry with our
method? The answer is yes. The only difference
is, we can change our basis from the Legendre
polynomial to the final element polynomial,
like p1 p2 polynomial basis, then we can do it.
So the architecture is pretty much same.
The difference is we can replace our polynomial
from Legendre to the p1 or p2 sometimes p3 p4
then we can enjoy this kind of the
complex geometry by using the domain
Triangle, triangle triangularization. So the
idea is pretty much same. So we have this kind
of the easy toy problem, like the reaction
diffusion equation. Then we can think of the
weak formulation. So this is the left hand side
and this is right hand side. Then we can give
our loss function by using the left hand side
minus right right hand side, the residual form.
And then we can train, once again by using this
radio Register Form. Then that's it. So that's
the our, the final element operator networks. So
again, I showed our architecture. So we have um,
our, the given first income input, forcing them.
And then we have a we can predict this kind of
coefficient by using the neural networks. And then
this is p1 p2 element basis, whatever p1 p2 each,
our choice. If you go to the p2 element, then
code for the p2 element, then you can make this
kind of solution prediction, and then make a
loss form, and then train this neural networks,
and then going again, again. This kind of
the process like, you know, 1000 epochs,
then we can get the accurate numerical solution
by using the operator networks. Again. This is
unsupervised neural networks, so we don't
need any pre computed data set. And this
and the inference each we can
do the multiple instances. So.
So given input, forcing them,
sometimes initial condition,
sometimes boundary condition, which
are input, then they can predict,
without further training, predict the numerical
solution by using these kinds of neural networks.
So for instance, which we tested this one
is, I think, on that is the Poisson equation,
or convection definition one of the equation.
This is a linear equation. And then the domain
is kind of the square with whole polygonal
shape of the domain. And then we our input
each given f function, forcing function
like this, and this forcing function,
forcing function like this. And then I'm sorry
they they just predict our the the numerical
solution very well. This is ground truth, and
this is ours, and that is devonet with only 30
the data set, input output pair. So of course,
divide with 3000 data set. They can do better,
but um, ours are the unsupervised. So we
just tested with a very small data set,
if we have zero data set. So I think I'm just kind
of a fair comparison and where ours are better,
and also polygonal shape. This is
ground truth, and this is the hours,
and this is deep, only 330 data sets.
So ours are also quite accurate.
And this is another the interpretation, so,
ground truth. This is our input and ground truth,
and this is ours which is good. And this is d1
with already data set, which is a little bit,
you know, a little bit difference between here
and there. And this is physics informed so. And
then this is another case of the physics inform
the one that they can. They cannot capture the
solution very well, but ours are capturing
very well. Look at this kind of the ground
truth and hours. Hours are fine element
operating networks. So ours are better.
And then we tested many different domain,
Domain One circle. Domain two, scale with
the whole. Domain three, polygonal shape and
different boundary condition, homogeneous,
recline, homogeneous. Neumann with this kind
of equation, and also equation one and two,
which is some general second order linear
equation. Equation two is Virgos equation,
which is non linear. And then we tested it.
Basically everything is like the percentage error,
like the hour errors are the without know the
training data set, hours are like the 1% and 0.5%
0.1%
0.3%
quite accurate, you know, error
prediction, so compared to the
physics informi net and compared to the
debo Net. So of course, we have a d1 with
3000 supervised data set each sometimes it's
good, sometimes it's bad, because, you know,
we have a very complex geometry, but ours are
concretely consistently. Have a good prediction
and the variable coefficient, so we have an input
is a coefficient of the given the given PDE,
for instance, we have CX is coefficient
in front of the convective term for the
convection diffusion equation. Then they can still
predict a nice numerical solution. And also input
as an initial condition, they can predict nice
numerical solution, and we can do the little more
complicated problem, like the stocks equation.
In that case, we using the tailorhood, the p2 p1,
alpha, the final element method, they can predict
quite well. And also we give a input the boundary
condition like this, and this part of the boundary
condition, then they can also boundary condition
as an input, they can predict very well. So these
are the comparison table. So we compare our method
with the pod devonet, which is an upgrade version
of the devonet. So coefficient divide with 1000
data adjusted a little better. But basically
hours are zero data set. So hours are concretely
fine. So and then we make this kind of the error
analysis. So like the this is what we do in the
numerics. So number of elements increasing, how
the look like, the relative error it's decreasing
at number of elements decreasing, and the error
also decreasing, but this is a little dent, so
I'm going to talk about this one quickly later.
So this is p1 and this is p, this is 1d
and this is 2d and the red one is p1,
blue one is p2, element method.
So, okay, I have only five or 10 minutes. So,
so So my method, our method, is also good for
this kind of singular perturbation problem. So I
think many of you already knew what's the singular
perturbation problem? They can produce bounded
layer or interior layer problem. So like this
kind of the problem, as epsilon decreasing and
decreasing, then they can produce very sharp.
Transition near the boundary or near the
interior. So it's really hard to capture
by using the classical numerical method.
Of course, they can use some other image
refinement. They can do better, but cholesterol
numerical method, it should be hard to capture.
And also in machine learning, which is very
hard to capture because they are related to the
spectral bias. So spectral bias, they can learn
the high frequency later. So it's this kind of,
the sharp transition, they can interpret it
as a high frequency, high frequency. So they
can learn this kind of the high frequency very,
very slowly. Or sometimes they cannot learn this
kind of the high frequency. So they are closely
related to do this kind of the spectral bias. So
single perturbation problem quite important
when we use when we handle scientific motion
learning problem. So how can we handle this kind
of scientific the singular perturbation problem,
by using our method. So we go back to the our
the singular perturbation analysis in PDE,
and then we are going to use this kind of PD idea
into our neural networks. That's our idea. So
I don't have enough time to always keep this
kind of analysis apart quickly. So think
about this kind of simple convection diffusion
equation and zero boundary condition problem,
and from here we can make asymptotic analysis.
So asymptotic analysis means that we can capture
only for the sharp transition behavior nearby
the boundaries. So this is like our asymptotic
equation. So they are we call this one is boundary
layer solution. So when we solve this boundary
layer solution, that we can capture this kind
of sharp transition profile, whatever this is
one big problem to the problem. And for this kind
of the convention diffusion type of the equation.
So boundary layer profile is e to the minus x
over epsilon. That is for this so called character
function. And in theoretical PDE, by using this
character function, they can solve this kind of
vanishing viscosity limit problem theoretically.
But in our method, we are going to capture only
this character basis, the corrector part, and then
make it this one as our our another enriched basis
function. So this is like the p1 our finite
element, classical basis and then we can add
this character function into our basis function.
And then we know this character function by using
the singular perturbation analysis. And then this
is called the enrich the basis method. So we can
enrich our bait, our final element basis, by using
this character function. Then this is our new
the finite element space. And then we can do the
dialogic process by using this new final element
basis, and we can capture the sharp transition.
So this is an epsilon equal to one case,
so they have no boundary layer for this equation.
So they can do very well by using our The final
element neural networks. And this epsilon
10 to negative five, they cannot capture the
this kind of sharp transition because of the hero
boundary layer, epsilon, tetra, negative five, but
we add one more basis which is no further, no
specific for the cost one more basis function,
and then they can capture this kind of
sharp transition very well. This blue one
is exact solution. This red one is predictive
solution by using the hour The final element,
neural operator, the fail net. So adding
this basis function, we can capture this
kind of sharp transition so we can handle single
operator, patient problem very well. And um,
time dependent problem. I will show you
this kind of time dependent problem by
using the this video. So this is like
nu is 10 to a negative five ish and
our u zero. Initial condition. I will
show you the initial condition, oops.
Initial condition is very smooth. Initial
condition. This nu is small, then they can develop
this boundary layer very quickly. But
this blue one is the exact solution,
and red.is our predictive solution by using
the our The final element of product networks,
by using the new basis function. And they
can capture this sharp transition very well.
So we can capture this kind of the
boundary layer phenomena quite well,
and the integrity Layer, Layer case, this is a the
fNo and CO M. FNo is like the three
per AI paper recently published 2024
they used some kind of the similar idea by
using the the Atlanta method, and they have a
900 training data set, but our method fail,
net, the finite element operator network,
without no data, we have a 10 to negative five
accuracy for this kind of inter layer problem.
But you know the other method, they are good 10
to negative three. But our results little better.
But we have no training data. They have a training
data. So that's the difference. So this is inter,
inter cases, and then we can do the many different
cases, like the 2d and circular and elliptical.
And this kind of the polygonal shape, we can,
you know, have a further extension. And in fact,
I didn't do this polygonal shape. This is
another example, but I'm I'm pretty sure we
can do this kind of the polygon shape by doing the
our the film net with some special basis function.
So three minutes i Two minutes I have um.
So let me just talk about the quickly,
the convergence analysis. So our approach actually
based on the numerical PDE method. So we know,
so we tried this kind of the rate of
convergence, kind of the analysis,
so number of elements, this is related to error.
So in FEM we know that p1 p2 element, we have
the rate of convergence, negative two, rate of
converts negative three. So we theoretically,
we can enjoy this kind of the the convert,
nice convergence for the p1 p2 the blue,
dotted, dotted one. But by using
the final element operator networks,
we decreasing this, increasing
the number of elements.
Then error going down, and then suddenly
they are going up. Also arrow is going down,
and then suddenly the error is going up.
So I thought that at the beginning. Oh,
maybe this is problem for the neural networks
optimization. So maybe we can make make use
of the larger neural networks, then we
can enjoy the better convergence rate.
That's our the first thought. But actually
it's not. We changed our neural networks,
change the optimizer, then this kind of
phenomena keep, you know, appearing in our
analysis. So why this happening? Why this? What
are these hiccups? So we dive into the the the
convergence analysis. So our method, in fact,
our method is based on the numerical PDE,
so we can do the convergence analysis by
using the classical numerical analysis.
So it's like the CS lemma, brown Bucha and
convergent theorem, which is in the FEM and
spectral element method. We know this kind of
the error analysis, so we can make use of this
kind of similar error analysis for the scientific
machine learning. So I'm not going to dive into
approximation, generalization, optimization.
Let me skip those parts. So, in fact,
we make the our the error estimate for our,
our final element, neural networks. Then we
have this kind of the on the error bound. So
that means this, what is kappa? A? Kappa a,
like the condition number of our the weak
form matrix. So that means this condition
number actually bothers our convergence. So we
have, like the high condition number, then our
numerical error, relative error going down
to number of elements increasing. We know
condition number is larger. So that's why
they have this kind of the kickoffs like
this and this kind of and this red one is like the
theoretical error bound by using this kind of the
the our the upper bound. So we can make use
of this upper bound, and then we can just
sketch it so it's pretty much same. So that is
theoretically we can prove it. So how can we
handle this kind of the hiccups? Of course,
we use the more number of the elements,
more more number of the neurons, then we
can actually relax this kind of the hiccups.
And another idea. So take n, large, M,
large. That's one idea. Another idea,
we can use the preconditioning. The
once we can use preconditioning,
we can just handle this kind of the
high condition number. Then you know,
with the preconditioning, we can have a better
numerical errors without the preconditioning
part. So that's one of the idea. So of course,
this is just upper bound, and we didn't take into
account the optimization error. So optimization
error, this is different animal, so we have
to enter more carefully. So that's kind of the
our the, you know, ongoing research. So we are
going to develop more and more this kind of the
analysis part by using our the neural networks. So
can let me skip this part. So we, we, I also
interested in this kind of the foundation model
for serving PD, but I'm not going to talk about
this today. So let me introduce my collaborator,
Professor sung chan go and Jamie Lee and
Nam June Kim. And these are my postdocs,
you know, che and Jin Sili, they can help me
to this kind of simulation and analysis all
together. So we have a good team so we keep
working on this direction. And of course,
you know, this is not the best way to handle
the PD problem by using the scientific.
Machine learning. So but you know, we can study
more and more, and then we just feel that there
are many more interesting parts of this kind
of scientific machine learning for the moment.
So that's the references. So thanks
for the attention. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you so much for the wonderful talk.
Let's have a Q, a sessions if you have
questions, and let me see the chat room,
I don't see any question there.
So if you have questions,
please unmute yourself and ask questions
while you are thinking about the question.
I guess I can ask some questions.
So your your method is unsupervised
method. You don't need a data. So what?
What about the the computational cost like,
like is it? Is it faster than the
traditional, you know, way of solving,
like the using the finite element
method or finite volume method or
or is it slower, just like the teams,
physics and function, okay, so, frankly,
so that in the for the training, it takes
longer time than fVm and fovm, of course,
but um, by doing inference, we have,
um, much faster, you know, because, um,
we are inference is just on one neural
networks, just, um, you know input that
output process. So if you want to predict like
5000 your numerical solution very quickly,
then I would recommend our methods better.
But you know, if you want to find them 10
to a negative 12 numerical solution, then
maybe you have go for the spectrum method
or discontinuous color method takes better.
Okay, so when you say training is slower,
but once it is trained, you can inference.
But when you when you do the inference,
can you like inference on many different
cases which you haven't trained on? Yes,
okay, so that that details, and I think I have
to Yes, yes. So like, um, if you have a different
forcing, Tom different initial condition,
then they can predict very fastly, like the
microseconds. They can predict many things, but
also, yeah, and I didn't specifically mentioned
the foundation model things, but, um, my dream
is like the Make a foundation model, like the
make a different equation, different geometry,
and then predict everything at once, but once
it is trained, yeah, once training is done, and
multitasking, multi problem, yeah, multi Yes, but
that's my dream, so it's quite far fetched right
now. But, um, you know, it's my first, you know,
step. Oh, awesome. Okay, I have another questions.
One of the things in for the singularity,
the problems, you know, in order to capture the
sharp feature, you have to add, like auxiliary
basis functions. What kind of basis functions Did
you add? So okay, that's very good question. Thank
Thank you, because I didn't have enough time so
I didn't specifically introduce much the correct
basis so I'm the in classical numerics. I studied
them, the enriched basis, finite element, spectral
element method, sometimes finite volume method. So
I don't want to use adaptive measure refinement,
because which quite is expensive, but I want to
solve this kind of the boundary layer interior
problem. So in that case, we can add one more
basis, like the enriched basis, and they can
get they are basically boundary layer interior
solution by using the asymptotic analysis. Yeah.
So you can make asymptotic analysis for the
given PDE. You can predict what you can you
can actually calculate what is the boundary layer
solution, like the inner solution, so inside the
boundary layer, and then whatever this is 2d
or 3d the solution profile could be 1d profile,
because if you have a very nice boundary layer,
so of course, if your geometry is very much ugly,
then maybe the bound your character,
the basis function, is also ugly. Or
maybe if you have some nice kind of the domain
shape, and you can find this kind of good the
the corrector function, then you can add
this character function to the your the
final element basis. It is called the
enrich, define element method. So I
just made use of this new basis function
into our The final element operators. So,
okay, it's basically PDE, kind of the
oriented idea. Okay, awesome. Okay,
so the young, young, do you have questions?
Yes, yes, please. Can you use the idea to
other
the final difference, final volumes and.
In the message, or probably
having those kind of classical,
yeah, that's very good question.
I I'm actually thinking that, um,
how can we, um, make use of this idea
into the final volume method? But um,
one thing bothers is that,
um, we I have to compute flux,
and it's like, it's not very easy to think about,
how can we just predict fluxes and for different
geometries? So it's not very straightforward. But
I'm also thinking about, how can we apply this
idea to the finite volume method? And you know,
I'm kind of defending the final volume method,
so because they have a conservative structure,
so I love that, yeah. I'm still thinking,
yeah. I think that's great, yeah, because combine
the crash computing method with AI the new
methods. So those all and new coming together,
I think, as you demonstrate in your talk,
is excellent, wonderful, congratulations. Thank
you. Thank you so much. Thank you. Alright,
we have another question from Kevin. He's
asking, Does the neural network outputs all
coefficient values of the basis functions,
or are there are multiple neural networks,
each outputting one coefficient value. Oh, it's
like the neural one neural networks outputs to
all coefficient values of the basis. So your
output could be vector of the coefficients,
and the dimension of the output could is like
number of coefficients you
have, yes, exactly, yeah.
Okay, sounds good. Is there any other questions?
If not, let's thank our speaker,
Young Jun, for the nice talk, and
hopefully, after this presentations,
a lot of people is going to reach
out to you, and then, you know,
ask questions, and also, you know,
establish a future collaborations.
Thank you so much. Yeah, okay,
awesome. Well, with that,
let's end our DDPS seminar today.
Let me start the record button. Do.